the big news of the day is that joe
biden has basically decided that
remember all that monoclonal antibody
stuff that rhonda sanchez was talking
about and members of the media were
suggesting that he was just sort of
making it up why aren't you focusing on
vaccines and the answer was he was
focusing on vaccines and then for people
who did not take the vaccine or for
people who got a serious breakthrough
infection or for people who would not
take the vaccine it is very good to have
monoclonal antibodies on hand because
they are a very effective treatment from
regenerons the media immediately shifted
into anti-desantis mode which meant that
we were all blowing monoclonal
antibodies out of proportion we really
should you know it's really not a thing
why are we focusing on this thing and
not only that rhonda sans is probably
doing this because he might own stock in
regeneron or one of his donors own stock
in regeneron it's probably all about
that well now it turns out of course
that rhonda census was correct because
as he has throughout this pandemic
rhonda census has been following the
science
and so he ordered a lot of monoclonal
antibody treatment because florida had a
really big spike you may have noticed
this summer and the treatments that were
available included monoclonal antibodies
well now the biden administration has
stepped in and they've said okay we're
no longer going to allow states to
simply order monoclonal antibody
treatments now we're going to federalize
the process and in the process remove
doses from places like florida
which is pretty obviously a revenge play
by the biden administration against
states like florida and like texas
because the idea is that they're going
to what pick up doses and then not send
them where they're most needed see
here's the thing about the market
especially when you have states who are
competing to get a limited supply of a
good the states that have greater need
of the good are generally willing to pay
more
these states like florida that were in
dire circumstances should pay money
where states like new york we're not and
if new york spikes then new york
presumably will want to buy a lot of
monoclonal antibody treatments if states
like vermont which by the way is 88 of
adults in vermont are now vaccine they
have their all-time high in delta
infections because delta is infectious
and herd immunity seems not to be really
a thing when it comes to delta
if vermont wants monoclonal antibodies
they should go out and get monoclonal
antibodies but the biden administration
has decided and it is obvious what
they're doing that they seek to depress
i mean at this point they are basically
just rationing medical care
so breitbart has a very good report
on this from hannah blow
the biden administration this week
slashed the doses of life-saving
coronavirus antibody treatments in
florida giving the state less than half
of what it is of what is needed for a
routine week prioritizing what they
called equitable distribution aha
equitable not need based equitable now
you'll remember that in the public
health context the biden administration
when they use the term equity what they
really mean is we're not going to give
this treatment to the people who need it
most we're going to give it to the
people we want to have it most so they
did this first when they proposed the
cdc that they were going to tranch out
vaccines not by age which is the number
one complicating factor for covid but
instead by race
remember they suggested they were going
to give a disproportionate number of the
vaccines to black americans not to
elderly americans which made no sense
because the actual absolute number of
black americans who would then die would
be higher
because again if you have a certain
number of black americans who are in the
plus 65 crowd those folks are much more
likely to die than the 20 year old black
americans the the cdc didn't care they
were going to try and give a lot of
doses to people who are 20 and not a lot
of doses to people who are 65 and then
there is public outcry and blowback and
the cdc revised its own standards
whenever they say equity what they mean
is we are not going to actually
triage this situation and get the doses
where they are most necessary instead we
are going to simply focus in on who are
our political constituencies and how do
we get them what they want
the biden administration this week began
to cut the distribution of monoclonal
antibodies to red states like florida
and alabama contending those states
including texas mississippi tennessee
georgia and louisiana are comprising too
big a share of the supply in recent
weeks 70 percent
okay well shouldn't we actually
determine the supply by where the
hospitalizations and deaths are
occurring
wouldn't that be the way that you
normally do this
it's sort of like saying that you have a
heavy urban area and a lot of rural
areas and there are a lot of car
accidents in the heavy urban area but we
only have a certain number of doctors
who are available for car crashes and we
know that in the rural areas you know
those people are our voters what if we
just send all the doctors for the car
crashes out of the rural areas which
have fewer per capita car crashes and
those people in the in the cities i mean
they chose to live there so they're
getting a car crash really kind of their
problem right
a spokesperson for the us department of
health and human services said hhs will
determine the amount of product each
state and territory receives on a weekly
basis state and territorial health
departments will subsequently identify
sites that will receive product and how
much the official continued claiming the
system will quote help maintain
equitable distribution both
geographically and temporally across the
country providing states and territories
with consistent fairly distributed
supply over the coming weeks and all the
ambiguity lives in that word fairly
because again normally you don't have to
worry about what's fair you just have to
worry about who's sick
as soon as you substitute the word fair
for ill in that particular sentence
you have decided that the ill don't
matter all that matters to you is your
political priority
right instead it should be that the
geographic and temporal distribution
should be rooted in who is ill
again they don't care about that they
care about the politics
governor ron desantis of course is
cracking back against the biden
administration
and by the way this is this just
demonstrates the lie okay so first of
all you'll go back like a week and a
half joe biden is yelling at the
unvaccinated and one of the things he
says in his speech yelling at the
unvaccinated is we're going to radically
ramp up the amount of monoclonal
antibody available to people unless you
happen to live in a red state in which
case you're screwed
we're increasing the availability of new
medicines recommended by real doctors
not conspiracy conspiracy theorists
the monoclonal on antibody treatments
have been shown to reduce the risk of
hospitalization up to 70 percent for
unvaccinated people at risk of
developing severe severe disease
we've already distributed 1.4 million
courses of these treatments to save
lives
and reduce the strain on hospitals
so there was like a week and a half ago
talking about how important it is to
distribute these monoclonal antibody
treatments right it's super important to
distribute these things and then he's
like what if we just shifted the way we
distribute these things so that the
people who are sickest don't get them
and people in blue states do
if donald trump had done this you know
what the reaction would be in fact there
were rumors early on remember there were
all these rumors that jared kushner had
said those blue states they don't need
their ventilators now that never
happened right the blue states got their
ventilators but joe biden's actually
doing it everything they accuse trump of
doing biden actually does and the media
cheer like the good little ceo seals
that they are according to breitbart the
feds have now delivered less than half
of the necessary doses to florida this
week according to cbs 12 they send 30
950 doses according to numbers from the
governor's office and confirmed by the
department of health normally the state
needs about 72 000 doses a week to meet
the current needs on the ground
christina pusha the press secretary for
desantis blasted the biden
administration's move suggested quote
every corporate media outlet that
publishes sensational stories about
overflowing hospitals in the south
should first demand answers from the
biden administration about why they are
restricting the supply of life-saving
coveted treatment to the south
she said supply of monoclonal ants body
treatment to florida alabama tennessee
texas and other southern states
restricted by the biden administration
with no real explanation besides equity
how is it equitable to only send
treatment for half the floridians who
need it and no state sites in alabama
so ron desantis slammed joe biden over
all of this as well he should here with
desantis
we are very very concerned
with the biden administration and the
hhs's recent abrupt
sudden announcement that they are going
to dramatically cut the number of
monoclonal antibodies that are going to
be sent to the state of florida we think
it will make a difference in these other
states but man to just kind of pull the
rug out from anyone a week after the
president himself said they were going
to be increasing the distributions by 50
percent uh it's very very problematic
it is very problematic and if you look
at the timeline when he says it's abrupt
it is absolutely abrupt now phil kerpin
over at the washington examiner he has
an entire timeline demonstrating that
until like five seconds ago there was
an actual guarantee to florida that they
were gonna get a certain number of doses
and then everything just switched
right as of september 9th president
biden announced his path out of the
pandemic a six-pronged comprehensive
national strategy to combat covet
and he announced that they would
increase the average weekly pace of
shipments of free monoclonal antibody
treatments to states by a further 50
in september and then september 13th hhs
announced they were taking complete
control and doing weekly distributions
for all states and territories that same
day
that afternoon the federal department of
health
communicated to h the florida department
of health rather communicated to hhs the
weekly need for just the 25 state run
sites of about 36 000 doses when hhs
mentioned the state receiving the order
for all state sites and distributing the
florida department of health
specifically asked if such a shift would
apply to all facilities in the state
providing treatment hhs said this was
not the case and did not provide any
indication of any upcoming limitation to
supply
and then the very next day they sent an
email to all stakeholders indicating a
shift to an allocation strategy had
occurred that day
and they were contradicting what they
had just told the florida department of
health this is obviously an eminently
political and what is this really about
this is really about joe biden and the
biden administration determining that if
you are in a southern state you do not
deserve the vaccine
this is purely political
because let's be real about this there
are major population centers in the
united states where there's huge levels
of vaccine refusal i'm specifically
talking here about black
constituencies across the united states
huge levels of vaccine refusal
and on par or more than
quote unquote trump supporters
and i'm not seeing any talk whatsoever
about denying treatment to people based
on that so if the basic idea is that you
get covered because you decided you
didn't want to get a vaccine
and then the federal government says
okay well you're on your own because you
did that then that should theoretically
be equally applied
otherwise what's the excuse
really what's the excuse
so the so biden himself says well it's
about texas and florida refusing
quote-unquote life-saving measures what
are these supposed life-saving measures
things like mask mandates
now again mask mandates have been tried
in nearly every state in the union
there's very little evidence that mass
mandates have done a damn bit of good
when people are scared of the virus they
put on a mask when they are not scared
of the virus they don't put on the mass
which is why you see in every state
including new york and california that
after a mass mandate is put in place
usually what happens there's a big spike
the spike starts to decline and then a
government actor being late on the ball
as always says mass mandate
and then the
the
spike continues to decline
we're on the other side of the of the
of the arithmetic curve right we're on
the other side of the curve already and
they say well it was because of this
right so the curve looks like this and
then mass mandate comes in here and then
just continues to decline and then three
months later there's a big spike
and where was your mass mandate well
very often it was still in place
this is happening all over the place so
he thinks mass mandates are the solution
or he thinks that
forcing businesses to vaccine mandate is
going to make this sort of stuff happen
when the reality is i mean i'm talking
to people every single day who are
vaccine hesitant and all that his
vaccine mandate nonsense has done is
pushed these people into a harder
position they've hardened their
positions it's now made them more
ideologically prone
to not only refusing the vaccines but
saying i'm happy to lose my job you've
turned what was a health decision into a
liberty decision for a lot of people and
people are going to double down on what
i think is a bad decision with regard to
vaccines but an understandable one with
regard to liberty but here's joe biden
basically saying you don't deserve to
get monoclonal antibody treatment i mean
that's really what this is about if you
don't do what i want you to do on mass
mandates in schools for example or if
you don't do what i want you to do with
regard to vaccine mandates for employers
now really if you were about getting the
vaccinated vaccinated
and denying them treatment then there
should be a simple
a simple policy right it would be a
vicious and cruel policy which is why he
doesn't want to do it out loud but he's
just doing it by state and trying to
focus in on red states but if these
simple quote-unquote moral policy here
is you don't get vaccinated you get the
disease you're on your own that should
equally apply across states should it
not but it's not here's biden
but we're facing a lot of pushback
especially from some of the republican
governors
the governors of florida and texas are
doing everything they can to undermine
the life-saving requirements that i
propose this is the worst kind of
politics
because it's putting the lives of
citizens of their states especially
children at risk
and i refuse to give into it
okay again this sort of tyranny from the
federal government that ron desantis is
the actual tyrant because he refuses to
force businesses
to mandate that people have vaccines so
ronda sansa says you're allowed to be
free make your own call in the state of
florida by the way if you're a business
and you want a vaccine mandate you can
still do that
but you actually can
so ron desantis says that and joe
biden's like he's the tyrant and it's
his fault so i'm now going to deprive
you of the treatment you need and
nowhere else in healthcare nowhere else
in the healthcare field do we do
anything like this it just does not
exist this notion that if you did not
take measures to protect yourself and
then you get hurt or you get sick we are
going to deny you treatment that does
not exist in the healthcare field
my wife the doctor heard about this and
you said what in the world is this what
in the world is this notion that if
somebody did not take measures to
protect themselves and then they got
hurt that the medical establishment is
supposed to refuse them treatment as
opposed to triaging by level of risk to
them level of risk to their health
right well this doesn't exist in like if
you're in a car crash and you weren't
wearing a seatbelt and they bring you
into the hospital does anybody go oh
this this jackass wasn't wearing a seat
belt because he gets what he deserves
and you know he's got some pressure on
from a hematoma and his skull but we're
just going to let that go
and just let that blame that that brain
bleed continue
no one does this
okay but but joe biden is pretty openly
doing this he's punishing states that
don't do what he wants
by centralizing monoclonal antibody
treatment distribution when the state of
florida was basically doing it on its
own already the state of florida was
already like we're getting the doses
guys
the biden administration says the
restrictions are in place to ensure
every state can obtain enough of the
drug
florida got about 30 000 doses in the
last week texas ranked second
the the goal here really is that he's
trying to cut off desantis at the knees
because here's the nice thing for him
joe biden
if things get worse in in florida which
they're not things are much better in
florida the the strain on the hospital
system has been relieved you can see
every single curve including
hospitalization and death in florida is
now down so we have hit the other side
of the curve we did a couple of weeks
ago in florida the next curve is likely
the next big spike is likely to be
midwestern and northeastern
okay but the goal here for biden is if
more people die in florida then he
doesn't have to worry about running
against desantis and florida it's so
overtly political it's insane
by the way this has been the schtick all
throughout the pandemic every debt that
happened under trump was trump's fault
every debt that happens under biden is
governor's fault that's the way this
magic happens according to the media
biden tweeted something similar
here is joe biden's tweet yesterday
he tweeted out republican governors in
states like texas and florida are doing
everything they can to undermine the
public health requirements that keep
people safe really because the rates of
vaccination particularly for the elderly
in florida stack up pretty well against
virtually all other major states in the
united states what are these measures to
undermine public health requirements
keeping people safe
forcing people to mask up
post-vaccination forcing children to
mask up sons any evidence
forcing employers to fire people and
take the food off their table if they
don't want to get the vaccine
he says they're playing politics with
the lives of their citizens especially
children i refuse to give into it
especially children the is he talking
about
i've got three kids his kids are all
grown you think i'm playing politics
with my kids i care about my kids a hell
of a lot more than joe biden does and i
care about my kids enough to know that
my five-year-old should not be forced to
wear a mask and eat outside on the
pavement every damn day
but apparently i just want to risk the
life of my kids according to joe biden
the white house is basically admitting
what they are doing
so jens hockey was asked about this
we're not restricting supply we're just
you know restricting supply
over the last month given the rising
cases due to the delta variant and the
lower number of vaccination rates in
some of these states like florida like
texas just seven states are making up 70
percent of the orders our supply is not
unlimited and we believe it should be
equitable across states across the
country do you have no reports of a a
lack of supply so why cut them to those
states only if there's no revenue i
think our role as the as the government
overseeing the entire country is to be
equitable in how we distribute we're not
going to give a greater percentage to
florida over oklahoma nor do i think are
you suggesting that
okay that's that's insane and the
dismissive nastiness of gensake really
is pretty extraordinary i mean that
she's dismissing people dying in
hospitals that's what she's doing right
there
okay she's it sounds all it sounds all
equitable
if you say equitable over and over
enough then three times and it appears
like beetlejuice
okay equity just appears there's only
one problem you don't trench out
treatments by percentage of population
you do it by who has the cases
there's not an er on planet earth that
would handle this the way that the
federal government is handling this and
it is done purely out of spite that's
all this is and it's spite for a
particular population namely people they
perceive to be trump supporters
that is what they are doing and how do i
know that it's about trump supporters
and not mere vaccine hesitancy
because that is perfectly obvious they
are not equally angry at all people who
are hesitant to take the vaccine
depending on who you are the white house
will be your very bestie they will call
you up they'll try to massage you into
getting the vaccine
only if you're a white house supporter
if however you oppose joe biden
then go ahead and die sucker as jimmy
kimmel might put it
the battle for the culture is heating up
we here at the daily wear are making
some big moves so be sure to like
subscribe ring that bell because you're
not going to want to miss a single
moment